we need and want people to be watching
what we do
as we do it football teams would prefer
to have people in the stands watching
what they do
as those teams do it the reality of
pandemic is the nfl is going to have
some inconsistent approaches to fans
who are allowed to be there and who are
not the nfl isn't going to say hey if
one team can't have fans
no team can have fans and a couple of
coaches are not happy about it here
are sean mcdermott the bills and mike
zimmer of the vikings making their
displeasure
known
yeah look it is what it is we control
what we can control i think it's
honestly ridiculous that there will be
that
uh you know on the surface what appears
to be
a playing field that's that's like that
and consistently across the league
you know with the different away
stadiums
but it is what it is we control we can
control that's got to be our mindset and
that's what we that's how we attack i
think there's some unfair
fair things going on around it as far as
uh you know some teams can have fans and
some teams can't
um so you know i think there's a
competitive disadvantage in some of
those
areas
here's the reality these guys are being
asked questions by
media during these video conferences and
this is an obvious topic to ask them
about it's not like they're
showing up with an agenda and saying i'd
like to make a statement right i think
we're going to be screwed
by this attendance policy but still they
are laying bare how they feel about it
and chris
i've seen no one credibly push back on
the threshold point
that it is unfair that it is a
competitive disadvantage
if one team has no fans
if another team in their division has
20 30 50 whatever percent
any percent is more than zero i remember
that from math
and yes it's inconsistent and thus
unfair because it creates a disadvantage
for the team that can't have fans
when it has to go on the road and play
in a stadium that has fans
yeah well oh okay i mean there's no
doubt about it
there is gonna be somewhat of a
competitive disadvantage
yes you know you would like to maybe
think the the nfl would think of
you know league uniformity as far as
like what it
what it what what they should do with
this issue no fans
because you know most of the teams can't
so hey all teams shouldn't be able to
but that's just not the reality of the
situation you know the first thing i
would say and something you said over
and over mike you said it a little
yesterday
i mean yeah the nfl is not going to make
the money it's made
the past you know 20 30 40 years
it's it's a pandemic so they need to get
as much money as they possibly can in
any which avenue
and whatever they can and then we know
that gets spread whether that's the 20
000
5000 20 000 hey that'll add up after 17
weeks of a regular season football
season and pay a lot of bills so i get
that and a year in a pandemic
we just got to be flexible that way and
then the other thing i'll just say to
this mike
i mean really do you think 20
000 fans is really going to set
a competitive advantage for a team in a
way where you're going to feel
uncomfortable about it
right like i don't know if it makes me
that angered hey i want to see
everything equal
but let's just say you're minnesota
vikings yeah they're
they're hosting no fans are you stuck
i'm not gonna why
why because i'm not go ahead okay so
don't get mad
all right all right so let's say they
gotta go on the road
and you know play a team that's got five
ten thousand maybe twenty thousand
are you gonna be angered i don't know do
you really think that twenty thousand
you'll be able to make enough noise to
really disrupt your team and
professionals and everything like that
i i don't i don't care i don't care
about it one way or the other because i
understand what they're doing
right why they're doing it one of the
first things my mom ever taught me was
the ben franklin quote a penny saved is
a penny earned well in this case
a dollar earned is a dollar saved
they're looking at seven billion dollars
by some estimates that i've seen
published in losses if no fans are
present for any games this year
seven billion between ticket sales
parking concessions all the stuff
they try to get you to buy when you show
up at the stadium that all goes away
if no one goes to the games so the
mindset is
anyone we can let come through the door
and
pay us to be at the game and pay for
food and pay for
beer and pay for a program if they still
have programs
and pay for this and pay for that that
that helps
rebuild this disaster of a season at
least financially for the nfl so i
understand why they're doing it and i
wish they would just say that's why
they're doing it
because i think people can accept it and
people can move on
now will 20 percent capacity
make a difference i don't know because
we've never seen it before
that's the key chris we don't know how
much noise they're going to generate
in a seattle stadium with only 20 there
but i'll tell you this
the way they've designed that damn thing
it doesn't take much noise
to get it focused right down on the
field
and right down on the opposing team's
bench so maybe they can do with twenty
thousand what they could do with sixty
thousand so
here's what the nfl's official position
is jeff miller the new head of pr
says that decisions are made first by
state and local health authorities who
make the determinations to whether or
not it's permissible
for any number of fans or none to
congregate at the site yes
of course that's how it works and that's
what they are deferring to dr alan sills
chief medical officer
obviously there are differences in the
state of the pandemic and state of the
infection as you move across the country
so the fact that there's not
one-size-fits-all approach shouldn't be
surprising given the medical situations
across the league okay but here's the
thing dr sills
they did use one size fits all for the
offseason program so
that's where the logic is falling apart
from march
until july there was an obsession with
making sure that the rules
that apply to one team apply to all
teams so if
california can't have any coaches in the
building no one can have any coaches in
the building
if if one state says no one's allowed to
show up for work then no one's allowed
to show up for work anywhere and they
eventually relaxed a little bit
but at the end of the day they took
great pains to ensure competitive
balance
as it related to the rules of the
off-season now that all goes out the
window
when it comes to saving as much money as
you can
and i wish they would just come out and
say just say it it's okay
it's okay to say look we are looking at
staggering losses this year
we're gonna cram every ass into every
seat that we possibly can yeah
just say that because that's what
they're doing well you're right that's
what they need to say i don't think
anybody's gonna be like oh man the nfl
you guys are ridiculous how s
how you know you know inconsiderate are
you you guys want more money in a year
you're gonna lose money
i mean yeah yeah i mean you're right no
one's gonna get mad at that
you know aspect in this day and age and
the in the
reality we're stuck in right now so i
i'm with you the nfl
they should they should just come out
and say that you know i guess
i guess the big thing is you know and
again i know you brought up like
hey everything was equal in the off
season and all that well i think that's
a little bit different you know just
just to say that out there because you
know it wouldn't be fair if one coaching
staff could work
and like work on game plans and do that
another coaching staff couldn't
now this still affects the competitive
you know advantage i'm not like
trying to say it doesn't but i don't
think it sways it into an effect to
where i
i'm angered by it as a fan and i don't
think it'll sway it enough to where
if you're a head coach or you're a
player you're gonna be angered by it i
don't think if you're
playing for the new york football giants
and you got no fans
and then if you got to go down to play
dallas first off you're just happy
you're playing football
most football players and if you have to
go down there and play the cowboys
who do have 20 000 you go ah i mean that
stinks but it's not going to be
like man you know i don't think guys in
the locker room will be like that's some
bs we need to talk to our player reps
and get something done here
i don't think it's that big of a deal
now i don't know
if it goes to like i will say this if it
goes into like the
above 50 capacity and then you have
teams
that have zero percent capacity still
because of their state rules
then i do start to look at it and go
whoa that can be a big number of you
know a lot of people in a stadium
you know fifty percent capacity in the
cowboys stadium i mean that could be a
little loud
certainly but again i just think we're
in a time where no one's gonna want to
hear it nobody
cares right now and the players are just
gonna have to deal with it because this
is the way the rules and our country is
set up right now with the state by state
legislation
i think that's the threshold reaction
most people are going to have we got
bigger issues right
now to deal with right than worrying
about whether or not
a team that goes on the road is playing
in front of zero fans
10 000 fans or 60 000 fans
big deal just be glad that they found a
way to play the damn game it doesn't
matter who's there
that's my threshold position and then i
fall back to
the reality that this is a business i
know see this
is why let me choose my words carefully
here
this is why they say football is family
not football is business and this is why
they're not going to come out and say
hey folks look it's a pretty simple
analysis here
we're trying to make money we're not
doing this for the greater good
we're not doing this as some sort of
civic enterprise we're doing this to
make
every last dollar that we possibly can
so in that spirit of american capitalism
yeah sorry vikings if you can't have any
fans and you have to go play
in a stadium where there's 50 capacity
sucks for you but not for us because
we're trying to make money and we're
trying to do what we can to avoid the
losses from the pandemic it's it's so
obvious
that's why it doesn't bother me it's so
obvious yeah right
because i understand it's a business but
see now i've answered my own question as
to why they just won't come out and say
it
because football is family football
isn't business but football is business
and it's good for business to say
football is family
well i mean yes i think i i think that
makes you get and
i know you love that you know football
as family phrase that's one of your
favorites out
there it's a marketing slogan aimed at
enhancing a business come on people we
can still enjoy football
and understand that at the core it's a
business no i mean we know
it's it's it's very much a business it's
a very real business and anybody that's
been involved in it or around it close
enough you'll realize that in a hurry
um but yeah you know i i can't disagree
with you there
you know i don't know why the nfl
doesn't just come out and say that just
to kind of like settle the
you know settle the media the coaches
you know everybody down just to be like
hey this is the way it is this year
we're trying to scrounge together every
last dollar we can get
you know because we are a family and we
want to make sure the family gets fed
right i mean that's i know i just had to
have fun with that but
yeah uh yeah i'm with you there and i
don't have a big issue with it
and especially as a fan and especially
right now i'm just happy there's
football and i just don't give a damn
right now that yeah some some teams will
have fans and others won't
uh honestly it adds to an another
interesting
kind of psychological dynamic to this
season
in which i'm excited about this year to
see how this unfolds and how teams
handle it all
and let me just say a far greater
concern for every coach in the nfl
than whether or not his home games won't
have fans
and his road games may have fans rooting
against him
is the reality that whatever the hell
happened over the weekend at the
bioreference laboratory in new jersey
could happen
again we talked about this yesterday on
pftot
when the statement came out explaining
what happened
and when you look carefully at the 93
words that were issued by
bioreference laboratories they don't
know what happened or at least that's
their official position
so the coaches and the gm's and the
players and everybody's going to be
walking around wondering
when's that gonna happen again since
they don't know what it was if they
don't know what it was they don't know
how to stop it that's a far
greater concern from my standpoint if
i'm an nfl head coach
then whether or not fans are going to be
there i mean for some of the teams that
travel well
maybe they should be happy that fans are
going to be there when they go on the
road maybe it's going to be their fans
what it could
be who are more likely to show up than
the home fans well yeah you're right
maybe they'll just be hungry for
some sort of you know viewing pleasure
to be able to see their team
in person and yeah they travel down to a
place like
you know i was just looking at the
minnesota viking schedule just to look
at it there yeah they got a trip to go
to the houston texans maybe you know
that's what he's looking at
states like that houston you know maybe
tennessee maybe he's looking mike
zimmer's looking at the early part of
the schedule going damn
we gotta go and play some teams that
yeah are in some states where
i think they're gonna have crowds and
and we're not gonna have that
maybe he just doesn't like that and just
you know of course it's brought to us
attention but
uh i got no issue with it i'm i'm not
concerned with it with the slightest
you're right i'm more worried about guys
staying
covered free the testing staying you
know
strong like you know like you just
talked about and we'll see where all
this leads
i don't expect the nfl to make any thing
happen not going to change right no
no no they're not going to change look
it's worth us talking about it so people
understand exactly what's going on
at the end of the day they're not going
to change this chris the one development
that i would expect and maybe we'll know
about it maybe we won't will be
a memo could be a memo should be a memo
if the league wants guys like mike
zimmer and sean mcdermott to stop
talking about this
telling all the coaches and gm's and
owners and everyone else don't talk
about it because they did that
prior to the draft yeah right they sent
out they said they sent out the memo
saying there will be discipline right if
you
talk publicly about our arrangements for
the draft or express concerns about
going forward be optimistic
they kept saying to the teams and the
coaches before this all went down and
training camp and all that so yeah
you're right send out another league
memo get everybody on the same page so
yeah people don't get this disgruntled
and you know it gets lost in translation
through the media and everything like
that
i posted something this morning before
the show vic fangio the broncos coach
has the right attitude says i don't give
a damn about that
but you can't control it right that's
the thing you're not going to change it
they're going to go forward unless the
coaches are looking
and it's it's it's way too early to be
building excuses for a failed season
into your talking points or maybe it
isn't maybe it's never too early to set
yourself up to say
well this is why we stunk this year but
mike zimmer just got a new contract sean
mcdermott just got a new contract that's
the last thing they should be thinking
about
is setting up excuses in advance if they
fail this year if they were on the hot
seat it'd be different
those are the coaches that i would
expect chris to be making these
complaints because they're trying to
line up everything they can point to oh
yeah when it's time to go to the owner's
office
after you go six and ten and the owner
says why shouldn't i fire you well item
number one
we got screwed this year competitively
because we weren't allowed to have fans
and everybody else was
right well yeah i mean you know to echo
something you said early on
again these were questions they were
asked to it wasn't like i don't think
they're looking to make excuses or
anything like that
i do think as competitors they're
probably a little bit just like
man that's messed up i mean we're gonna
have to go there and
you know maybe have some silent calls at
the line of scrimmage and do that and
then they're gonna come to us and it's
just gonna be free rain
i understand them having that thought
but i just don't think it
holds any water per se in a year like
this right now
let me go extra next level cynicism uh
oh here we go
you ready are you ready i'm ready and
and i haven't
done this in advance yes this this just
came to me this just came out
so i can make no representation as to
whether or not this is going to be worth
anything
having said that what if the league
isn't troubled
by guys like zimmer and mcdermott
complaining about the potential
competitive imbalance because
that creates a nice little buffer
between what they're saying
and the reality is it's a business and
we're just trying to chase dollars here
and if if they never because that's what
they could say
that's what zimmerman mcdermott could
have said instead of we think it's
unfair we think it's ridiculous to have
these different standards
they could say what we're saying well
hey it's a business folks if you haven't
been paying attention
football is family no it's a business
and this is about making as much money
as possible or saving as much money as
possible
maybe maybe the league at large prefers
that the coaches complain about
potential competitive imbalance
instead of pulling back the curtain and
saying look folks
we're just trying to we're trying to
maybe
minimize the seven billion dollars that
we otherwise would lose if no fans are
present and i don't i still don't know
why they have any reticence
to let people understand that that's the
way it is because we all know just like
with college football we all know what
they're trying to do
money machine going even if they don't
have classes in person
they want football in person if there
was a way they could make that money
by not having football in person i
guarantee you they would do it let's
take a look
at the teams that may be helped and the
teams that
but maybe we don't know and won't know
what it means to have partial capacity
to a home field advantage until it
happens
but the five best and five worst home
records since 2017. here's the graphic
the patriots are the best now it's just
look i don't know it has anything to do
with having fans present
and the browns are the worst and i don't
think that has anything to do with
having fans present
so i don't know how much the home field
advantage comes into play i think it
does for the saints
for the chiefs for the vikings and the
look i
i was i was at the viking stadium before
they opened it they have engineered that
stadium
to send the sound right to the opposing
sideline the way that
yes i know is slanted right right that
wasn't accidental
the sound goes straight down to the
opposing sidelines so
i don't know if it'll work with ten
thousand or twenty thousand it
definitely won't work with none
but you know i i don't know how much
having the crowd present really helps
anyone especially if it would be a
partial crowd
well yeah you're right i don't know
either now those teams that we just
showed there
the the the top teams you know with the
best home records and all that
that it is real i mean it is all five of
them baltimore
i think is the one of the loudest
stadiums in football now you know you're
right mike
new england isn't it's a regular season
game like you said it's the preseason
they don't care
no engaged until the post it is not but
there is
you know but you're right there's a
mystique in there and those fans let you
know it
and they do have a great way of
you know i don't know talking trash
getting underneath the other team's skin
i mean you know they're a bunch of
boston guys they know how to get you
know underneath your skin in a hurry
they do so there is something to that
there but you're right i'm not like oh
my gosh the crowd is so loud in there in
new england
you can't hear yourself think like maybe
kansas city
or you know minnesota or new orleans
where you really can't hear yourself
that you know that to me will be
something to watch out for though
is the dome teams and will that how much
capacity will they allow like where
would new orleans be
because new orleans at 20 capacity
is going to be louder than almost
all outdoor stadiums at 24 capacity i
mean
you know those indoor stadiums it echoes
it traps that noise in there and there
is a difference there
uh but we'll see where it goes but yeah
some teams are certainly going to be
affected by not having their advantage
at home field like they do in years past
and then there's that lingering question
of this possibility of the nfl
using ambient noise fake noise i don't
know if they're trying to create a
baseline i'm very concerned about the
possibility for
shenanigans if anyone from the home team
has control of the knobs but i i
i can understand why they would want to
do it you know there was an item last
week in the atlanta journal constitution
chris of how the falcons are preparing
varying their snap counts using hand
signals using silent counts
for when everything can be heard crystal
clear we talked about that last week
the more easy it is for the offense to
hear the more
easy it is for the defense to hear and
they're going to pick up the rhythm
they're going to pick up the cadence and
you better change it up and the falcons
are talking about
changing their snap count changing their
cadence going to hand signals going to
silent count
just to keep the defense guessing and
preserve that split second edge and
folks that's where the
the noise becomes the biggest factor
the home team's defense benefits from
the fact that the visiting team's
offense potentially loses that split
second that lets them begin to execute
the play before the defense is
on them and that's the very real impact
of having a loud stadium for the home
team
yeah no no doubt about it i mean it does
it's gonna it affects communication
you know the the the the other thing yes
with these snap counts too you know i
don't know
you weigh this out mike you tell me you
know von miller
in a really loud stadium you know the
offensive tackle the offensive lineman
you know they're looking back at the
quarterback they're looking at the ball
wait is it being snapped there's von
miller
you know okay there's that disadvantage
right but von miller can't hear anything
either so he's going on movement as well
i don't know does he have more of an
advantage in that environment mike yes
i think so i think i think i think when
it's cloud okay
i think when it's loud for the for the
offense yeah
when it's loud for the offense it's more
likely to take away that
advantage of knowing you know the rhythm
that you can definitely when the play is
going to start because you know whether
it's on one or on two or on three and
you can hear it all
so you can anticipate it so you know the
way the quarterback talks you know what
the rhythm is you know when
two is coming right and that's when you
fire off if you're von miller
in that environment and it's loud and
the the left tackle that von miller is
trying to beat is waiting for movement
and von miller's waiting for movement
it's a tie it's even that
and it comes down to that boom just
there boom just there just that much of
a difference
between a left tackle having a chance to
redirect von miller and keep him from
getting around the left tackle and von
miller running right by him
yeah no i mean well it's interesting
because i also go
okay quiet stadium von miller you know
being able to hear the voice inflections
and things like that he's going to start
to get a really good feel for the rhythm
and tone of these quarterbacks too
to your point of why the atlanta falcons
are doing this
because they're probably realizing man
dante fowler grady jarrod if they can
hear the snap count all the time
holy cow you know they're and they have
a good feel and rhythm for
what on one is all the time and what on
two is all the time
yeah they're going to be hard to stop so
it is another interesting dynamic
to to think about and even on top of
that
i think the other thing that's going to
really have to go down just while we're
on this communication thing
is you're if you're an nfl quarterback
this year
you got to go into games i think with a
number of signals
for that one signal right where you
might have been able to get away with
you know and you know you might just be
able to yell the word
okay hey this you know whatever you know
lexus lexus okay
now everybody hears lexus the defense
knows what lexus is
you better have another way to say that
audible later or have another signal in
the bag
because if you go to it too many times i
do think it's the type of year where
teams are gonna
start piecing that together oh i heard
this on the tv copy he said this that
meant that
you're gonna have to be very aware of
what's said during a game
changing it up on a week-to-week game to
game basis so
you don't have signs and signals stolen
by the defense
and i think that's the human reality of
it you are out there
in that crucible when everyone's there
60 000 people and they're making all
that noise it's harder to process
everything that's happening that noise
becomes a distraction it becomes an
irritant at some point you get used to
it but it still limits what you can hear
yeah you take
everyone out of there and it's a
different vibe altogether and this is
what
teams need to plan for and i think part
of the problem is
they're not going to know until they do
it once they're not going to know what
it sounds like with only 15
000 fans present they're not going to
know what the issues are they're not
going to know how clearly the defense
they have to be ready
for every possible thing they're going
to have to change on the fly along with
all the other crap they have to worry
about
during a football game being flexible
and just
on the fly this is another thing that
they're gonna have to be ready
to factor in and make adjustments for
and and the more planning that's done in
advance
the better off you're going to be which
means the patriots will find a way to
figure it out before everybody else and
everybody else will copy them let's take
a look
at at the teams that currently have
allowed
fans because we know of places where
there won't be fans all year
right there are specific places where we
know going in
that there will be fans at the home
opener chief sixteen thousand colts
sixteen thousand eight hundred
dolphins thirteen thousand jaguar
sixteen
eight and how about the rams i thought
california would never
i was shocked given what's going on in
l.a but and here's the other side of it
too
just because that's the capacity doesn't
mean that's the actual attendance
remember the packers decided to go with
no fans their first two home games
because more than 80 percent of their
season ticket holders opted out
of their season tickets for this year so
just because you say
as the dolphins hey we got 13 000 seats
to sell it doesn't mean 13
000 seats are going to be purchased
that'd be interesting too just to see
that psychosis of how
you know how hungry are fans really to
get into that environment
and and really want to do that i'm
interested to see that as well because
of course
we haven't had that yet now in nfl
stadium of course did you go
would you go you know what mike i i feel
like
if i yeah i think i would i probably
wouldn't want to go week one mike i
probably wouldn't want to go week one
i'd want to see how it is but if i felt
like okay i've watched a week on tv
and there's two three seats in between
each individual and people are wearing
masks i you know honestly mike i think i
am one of those people that would go
call me crazy or stupid or whatever uh
but i would try to be very careful of
course and and take the right
precautions and all that
but yeah i think i'm getting at a point
in my life where i probably would go
and see ordinarily i would say i don't
want to go because i prefer to stay home
and watch all the games on tv and i just
don't want to go anyway because i just
don't want to deal with the crowds and
this and the other
now after being home for five months
i'll go anywhere i hear you
i'll go i'll go anywhere i was i was i
was talking over the weekend about
getting a new car and
and my wife said what so you can drive
to the bank once a week
so you can go to the grocery store once
a week so you go to the pharmacy
once a month it's like you know you're
right we really aren't doing all that
much right now so i
i i may be very inclined to hopefully
probably don't have a big enough garage
anyways right it's probably a really
small garage and you can't get another
car in there i'm sure it's really
tight you know tight fit there in
chateau dave florio
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports